germany's foreign minister says he wants
to do everything legally possible to
help iraqi kurds fight the militants
whether that includes sending german
weapons though looks unlikely for the
moment the defense minister says other
forms of aid are the main priority
we're looking to see what help we can
provide
it could be in the form of blankets
tents and medical supplies
but also helmets bulletproof vests night
vision equipment and trucks to name a
few items
but with the un warning of more
atrocities and even a potential genocide
some voices say that's not enough
elmar brock from the european parliament
is in favor of sending weapons directly
to the kurdish authorities
i think they have better state
structures in place than the current
rulers in baghdad who are engaged in
political infighting
so i think we'd make better progress
tackling these problems by dealing
directly with the kurds
others fear those weapons could fall
into the wrong hands and warned that
simply sending more arms into iraq might
not solve the country's problems
in addition to the questions of offering
military and humanitarian aid we also
have to think about what to do with all
of the weapons from the country's past
from what we've seen there are already
too many weapons in iraq
germany wants to coordinate its aid
efforts with its european partners
it will have the chance to do that at a
special summit of eu foreign ministers
on friday